bonsoir madame merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france on
vient d'entendre eric dupond moretti
il vous a convaincu lors de cette
allocution la sortie défensive du garde
des sceaux
écoutez oui enfin convaincu jeu
je crois surtout qu'il faut expliquer
que les magistrats
la justice est là pour contrôler la
police de façon générale donc si vous
voulez le conseil constitutionnel vient
de leur dire aujourd'hui c'est pas
monsieur dupont moretti qui l'a inventé
c'est que dans notre état de droit
les policiers doivent admettre que les
décisions judiciaires s'impose à eux
comme tous les citoyens un par ailleurs
sur le terrain effectivement il n'y a
pas vraiment de problème entre les
magistrats et les policiers puisque les
choses se passent bien dans le sens où
les textes des sites que le parquet ou
le juge d'instruction dirige l'action
des policiers qui enquêtent sur la
délinquance de façon générale vous
travaillez très bien en justice et
police sur sur le terrain alors quoi
c'est une affaire de 210 cas c'est vrai
que je vous dis voilà un exemple
syndicat alliance par exemple il ya trop
de différences entre la peine encourue
selon le code pénal la peine
effectivement prononcée par le tribunal
et la peine qui est réellement effectué
qu est ce que vous pouvez répondre à ça
parce que c'est aussi ce que pense une
partie de l'opinion française
oui en ce qui concerne effectivement par
exemple les agressions contre les
policiers
la peine encourue même si le policier
n'a pas d'incapacité de travail n'a pas
de blessure c'est quand même trois ans
d'emprisonnement ça c'est la peine
encourue
augmente en fonction évidemment du fait
que ya plusieurs personnes où il ya des
blessures jusqu'à dix ans
d'emprisonnement
donc la peine les peines prononcées ont
été doublé en dix ans en ce qui concerne
les agressions des policiers on en est
aujourd'hui à un nombre très important
de deux peines prononcées pour
l'agression des policiers c'est à dire
30 mille peines à peu près par an alors
que il y en a mais moitié moins
il ya dix ans donc on peut pas dire que
la justice n'est pas répressive et ne
punit pas les personnes qui agressent
des policiers maintenant il ya de la
part des policiers
un sentiment là l'impression qui n'est
pas la réalité des chiffres que ça ne
fonctionne pas comme ça maintenant
l'idée des peines automatiques
revendiquent les policiers elle est
contraire à notre constitution elle est
contraire à la convention européenne des
droits de l'homme est dans un état
démocratique la justice elle est là pour
prononcer des peines en fonction de
l'infraction qui a été commise des
circonstances si c'est par exemple
quelqu'un qui est complètement
alcoolique et qui se débat contre un
policier qui vient pour l'interpeller
c'est pas la même chose que quelqu'un
qui agresse directement toute
connaissance de cause un policier donc
et c'est pour ça que sont les juges sont
là et qui peut pas y avoir de peines
automatiques il faut adapter la sanction
à la situation et à la personne alors au
delà des peines
donc concernant des agressions contre
des policiers il ya par exemple je vous
donne un exemple de décision de justice
récente et affaires viry châtillon et
sarah halimi qui ont voilà générer des
manifestations même y compris dans la
population pour dénoncer une justice
trop clémente
comment vous le qualifiez madame sire
marin c'est un malentendu en même temps
c'est vrai que les magistrats sont pas
payés pour faire de la communication et
de la pédagogie mais il ya un grand
malentendu entre l'opinion publique et
la justice
ah oui je crois qu'il ya un grand
malentendu est sans doute un manque
d'information parce que viry châtillon
les policiers horriblement brûlé c'est
un c'est un fait
ce qui s'est passé c'était que c'était
une cour d'assises qui a prononcé cette
peine c'est à dire des jours et
populaire le peuple qui devient juge
neuf jurés et trois magistrats
donc la décision qu'elle soit ou pas
contesté c'est une décision de la
justice populaire
je crois que il ya actuellement des
plaintes en ce qui concerne la sphère de
viry-châtillon concernant des problèmes
de mauvaise retranscription on va dire
de ce qui a été dit notamment en garde à
vue par les personnes qui ont été jugés
et je pense qu'il y avait beaucoup
beaucoup de problèmes dans cette
procédure donc il faut comprendre que
les jurés et les juges ont rendu cette
décision après avoir étudié quand même
le dossier pendant une audience qui a
duré six semaines et ils ont délibéré
pendant 12 heures donc c'est impossible
de dire que c'est une décision qui est
injuste est là elle est extrêmement
motivé et donc on voit bien que ce que
contestent les policiers finalement
enfin les syndicats de policiers
certains syndicats c'est finalement
l'existence même du rôle de la justice
qui est indépendante en france et qui
n'est pas là pour homologuer en fait les
souhaits de l'exécutif ou de la police
contrairement à un certain nombre
d'états qui sont des états autoritaires
où la justice n'est pas indépendante
l'euro/dollar de la justice et
d'analyser les dossiers et s'il ya des
gens qui sont déclarés innocents c'est
que le dossier ne comporte pas
suffisamment de preuves et donc ça c'est
quelque chose que bon les policiers
police judiciaire savent très bien mais
je pense que les difficiles conditions
et fiction de travail des policiers de
maintien de l'ordre la police
la police la plus importante les rangs
un petit peu sourd à 7 à cette réalité
constitutionnelle
alors évidemment ça a été vous l'avez
constaté hier l'objet de beaucoup de
récupération politique puisque la
plupart des élus des partis excepté la
france insoumise étaient présentes
marine le pen dont qui a exprimé son
soutien à distance a déclaré au sujet de
la justice que le laxisme judiciaire
était un sujet de désespérance pour la
police est ce que vous craignez je
rappelle que c'est l'une des favorites
en tout cas selon les sondages pour la
future présidentielle de 2022 est ce que
vous craignez que que ce type de
d'opinion et de thèmes l'emportent dans
la préoccupation des français en 2022
oui c'est tout à fait possible on est on
est dans un climat qui est un un climat
qui est une sorte de critique absolument
permanente de la justice je crois que
c'est vraiment quelque chose d'inédit en
tout cas sur la vème république et moi
ce que je crains surtout c'est un
glissement si vous voulez de notre état
de droit vers un état qui considère que
la justice n'a absolument pas sa place
dans la démocratie ou tout au moins doit
être très relativiser et ça je pense que
ce serait extrêmement extrêmement grave
c'est plutôt ce que je crains et ça
c'est un lent une lente
dégradations je pense de l'opinion que
les les français ont de la de la justice
à travers aussi un certain nombre de
lois qui renouvellent en permanence
l'idée de la sécurité de la primauté de
la police finalement sur la justice et
je crois que il faudrait vraiment
remettre les choses un petit peu
alors droit à savoir que dans une
démocratie comme la france il ya trois
pouvoirs et que la justice l'ait enfin
la justice l'exécutif et le législatif
sont des pouvoirs qui doivent
s'équilibrer entre mais la police ne
fait pas un ne fait pas partie dans une
démocratie
du coup du pouvoir qui contrôle la
justice au contraire c'est exactement le
contraire
merci beaucoup madame evelyne sire-marin
jeu magistrate honoraire membres de la
ligue des droits de l'homme d'avoir été
avec mon direct sur rt france